bush was being interviewed by kimmel
and kimmel asked him a question says so
so let me ask you a question when you
become a president
do they take you into area 51 and tell
you all the dark secrets jfk all that
stuff what happened he says yes
are you willing to reveal any of it with
us no
so he did say that he said yes and then
he said no okay so
what was all that no secret talk but but
do you really think you're gonna tell
them
everything do you really think they're
gonna tell the president
do you think that's a good business
strategy play a game let's play a game
yeah
well bush could just walk down the hall
talk to his dad back then when his dad
was alive
yeah but for many years it's like hey
dad you know did you really install
chimpanzee as the president of honduras
yeah but that was just for fun that was
just kind of a weird weekend thing with
the cia
you know he says dad's going to tell him
everything
go ahead the old daddy approach go ahead
you were going to say let's say you
become president
pbd president pbd yeah all right
hypothetical
you're elected you're a two-term
president yep beloved
you're telling me that you wouldn't go
into area 51 you wouldn't go into the
cia and say i want to know about this
tell me this you wouldn't ask is what
i'm saying oh there's
no way in the world i'm not asking i've
never told you i'm not asking but i'm
saying they might not tell you i am
telling you it's not a good business
model to tell
it the only people that ought to know
the only people that ought to know is
not our kind of regimes
it's a regime like uk britain that the
same person is going to lead for 40
years
30 years not our model with the high
turnover the attrition
here's here's why not our motto you want
a guy to know something
who leaves the next guy comes and
trashes him for eight years hurts his
legacy
and that guy is going to go and use that
against the other politicians inside to
say
i swear to god if he says anything i'm
going to disclose this information
you don't think that kind of
negotiations happens behind closed doors
no you there's certain
it's a good strategy to tell presidents
everything no it's just correct and
remember we all the first week of any
presidency is retaliation
politics right what is every new
president for the last
four new presidents and it's not a
republican or democrat i think we've had
two democrats two republicans right
what do they do they issue executive
orders and then we're all looking at cnn
saying how many executive orders did
biden issue versus trump versus obama
versus bush
and all these executive orders come out
which is basically
undo this undo that undo this redo this
prohibit this enable this
and the executive orders are flying off
the shelves and so that the first move
is to use the executive order to bypass
legislative process on both sides
so you have retaliation politics and
stuff i'm with pat
you don't tell those cats a lot of this
stuff
because it's an impulsive
attention-based world
yeah you know what's really interesting
hollywood did a reasonable job with it
there's a great book out called charlie
wilson's war
about about a about the true story
wasn't it a movie
yeah i think tom hanks was in that yeah
and uh julie roberts it's a great story
hollywood did it was it was an
entertaining hollywood movie and
but the book clearly showed and there's
a lot of people that commented on the
book that said no this is way it happens
so watch the movie with some popcorn
enjoy it folks but then go read the book
and you understand what the clandestine
services group of our government is all
about
and you know i thought it was very
interesting a lot of people weighed in
and said hey this book was written by
charlie wilson yeah yeah yeah
but there's a bunch of things in here
that are very accurate for the way
that um groups within your government
have congressional hearings and do
secret
stuff and so i i don't want the new
president to know everything there's a
lot of stuff that yeah it's a risk
empty you don't want that you don't by
the way 130 people believe 130 people
press thumbs up
versus 11. so you're a megalodon
community it's 11 the ufo community 130.
so that many people believe
you've been watching uh meg too many
times with jason stadium i think that
you just
take off one week and go back to your
comments
go back to your usual uh so let's talk
about the story this whole thing with
michael
okay can i say last thing yeah go
forward that just shows how desensitized
we are
oh breaking news there's aliens all
right cool like did you just check out
my latest instagram post though
like that's how desensitized we are to
aliens
oh yeah they're they're there's aliens
they were here would be sensitive
meaning yeah it's here it's a part of it
i believe in aliens they were here
there's ufos it's no big deal all right
cool what's up did you what's on tv
tonight
you see what happened in the lakers game
yeah aliens where where you think it
ought to be
on everybody's aliens this is this is a
sort of a bigger deal than what happened
in the lakers game last night
in my opinion what a direct call out you
freaking guys
yeah i was telling you i went more
important than a lakers highlight last
night
shame on you the basketball community is
very disappointed in you right now
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye